all right happy friday everybody it's
time to get cooking right now with
nanny bubbe today she is showing us how
to make a delicious
spicy citrus skirt steak that sounds
so good manny bubby happy friday to you
are you cooking this on the
sidewalk you're probably gonna be real
yeah no kidding like i could cook and i
believe me i'm cooking i could probably
cook it on my chest i'm so hot after
so say spicy spicy citrus skirt steak
five times and we'll all be in trouble
right i know it but let me just yeah let
me just tell you a little something
about the skirt steaks
since that's what we're using before we
move on to more generic so this is a
skirt steak
and you can see how long it is right but
the thing is
is that you're going to want to cut a
skirt steak or a flank steak
or even maybe a sirloin so that it can
cook evenly on the grill because the
edges are very thin and the middle is
very thick
and so that is whoops got to move this
over exactly
what i've done here is you can see that
i have it cut into pieces so i went and
got that
the second one just just for you guys to
make that point and the other thing i
want to tell you alex is you want to
take your meat out of the refrigerator
about 30 minutes before you grill it so
it comes up
to room temperature but bacteria grows
at about 44 degrees above which is
refrigerator temperature
up to 165 when it's finished cooking so
what do you do so
you take it out you let it come to room
temperature then you bring it out here
and i mean it could grill itself just
outside right
and so what you do is you're going to
put this on a bowl of ice
so that it doesn't come up in
temperature way too much
just enough time for you to get it on
the grill and then the last thing i want
to tell you is since we don't have time
to make the marinade
because we're going to talk more about
grilling is that these are the items
that went into this marinade
and it is coconut amino apple cider
vinegar
uh blood orange olive oil sriracha
ginger
and garlic and that recipe can be found
on nannybubby.com nannybubbyfacebook or
instagram or gather with dannybubby
so this is the marinade i'm just gonna
toss it like this
and this is what i do a little
differently is i'm going to put this
marinade on
afterwards so it can rest in it and
absorb the juices
but right before i put it on i just got
it all over my sunglasses
oh no coconut aminos and apple cider
vinegar
never hurt anybody i'm just going to dip
it and then i'm going to take it
and i'm going to throw it on the grill
so let's talk
about a grill let's talk about the fact
that you always want your grill
to be clean right and the way to clean
your grill
is when you're done cooking before you
actually get to this so
last night i was done cooking i turned
my grill on high
while we were eating i let it go up in
temperature
and i let it just cook everything off to
ash
right yeah and then this morning when it
was cool i take a wire scraper and clean
it and
now when i turned it on to heat up now
this is that end
look at how thin that end is and so
that's why you don't want it to be
cooking with everything else so i'm
throwing this on
i'm throwing the last piece on really
quickly
and i'm also because of this recipe
which you can find online
these are oranges i'm dipping them in
the marinade whoops splashing it all
over
and getting that on the grill so the
last thing that we
not the last thing but the next thing
that we want to talk about is a spray
bottle
if you don't have a spray bottle then
what you need to do is put ice cubes on
the grill where it starts flaming up
we've all had that ignited flame up
stand back and that's water
and that's just water okay cool water
but it's been out here for an hour so
it's now boiling water but you know what
i mean
also i failed to mention to coat it with
olive oil
before you actually put everything on
which i did do
and then use an instant thermometer to
take it off
and so what you're going to do the most
important thing that i have to tell you
is i'm going to take this
marinade and i'm going to pour it into
the pot that i took
everything out of and when i take the
steaks
off the grill once i turn them i'm going
to put them back in this marinade
and it it will take about 15 minutes for
the juices to all settle
get back into the meat and also for the
marinade
which i do at at the end of cooking when
it's resting
and talking about resting cooking alex
if you're cooking medium rare steaks to
130 degrees
take them off the grill at 125 degrees
because when you put them in and put the
top on
to rest they come up five sec five
degrees
and the other tip i want to give you yes
and so you can
undercook everything about five degrees
the other thing is you don't want to oh
here we've got a flame
you don't want to do something that i
have always done which is compressing
the meat
which we all love for that flame to come
up
um but don't do that because you're
taking the fat and draining it out
and that's it that's all the tips for
cooking and grilling
that you need for a friday afternoon and
it was a pleasure doing business with
you alex i look forward to seeing
you yeah yet again yes oh my gosh thank
you so much you made that look so easy
nanny bubbe thank you
and you can check more out on nanny
bubby's kitchen and garden on social
media
and online at nannybuffy.com thank you
so much that was a great show and tell
that's something hopefully we can
replicate at home also want to say a big
thank you to chapman automotive for
sponsoring
this segment